ils étaient attendus par une dizaine de
camions de CRS au Murau les agriculteurs
ont été contraints de revoir leur projet
d'aller au triangle de rencour ce mardi
30 janvier au soir il est 23h la
centaine de tracteurs a été stoppés sur
la tr3e dans les de cens de circulation
à hauteur des paô nous allons voir avec
les forces de l'ordre quels
sont quel arrangement on peut trouver et
sinon bah on restera un petit peu de
temps ici on a tout notre temps nous
certains ont passé la nuit sur place
d'autres agriculteurs arrivent au petit
matin pour les remplacer et tenir
l'occupation la nuit à épone bah ça a
été long on s'est installé à 11h et puis
après dans les tracteurs bah c'est pas
confortable du tout en plus il y avait
les CRS avec les Giros bleus donc on a
du mal à trouver le sommeil quoi au
petit- déjeuner ce mercredi matin le
campement est installé à épune quelques
agriculteurs des ivelines et de l'UR
suivent les informations du bois pour se
chauffer de l'eau dans une citerne ou
l'alimentation stockée dans un food
truck tout est prévu pour maintenir la
pression sur le gouvernement après le
discours de politique générale du
Premier ministre Gabriel hatal ce qui
ressort d'un point de vue agricole de
ces de ces mesures n'est pas
satisfaisant ce mouvement français et en
particulier francilien etinois ici
attend d'autres réponses et et des
réponses beaucoup plus structurelles que
des réponses très conjoncturelles ou
voilà des réponses à des problèmes très
conjoncturels les principales
organisations de représentation du monde
agricole tentent de faire avancer les
discussions avec le gouvernement en
attendant les agriculteurs mobilisés sur
la 13 à hauteur des paôes continuent de
négocier avec les autorités pour
atteindre le triangle de r enc cour